m
[Musique]
quéral 1 m 20 52 cents débute dans la
revue à l'ange bleu après 31 ans de
carrière au théâtre et au cinéma je la
vocation de ce métier depuis que je suis
petit comme ça face a pas beaucoup
changé depuis l'an faim depuis l'âge de
sept ans après une représentation au tas
du trocadéro le trocadéro d'avant le
j'avais été impressionné par un
spectacle oriental pour enfants d'adam
et jamais décidé donc ça le faire du
théâtre je voulais être comédien vous
êtes rentré vous avez dit à vos parents
je veux être comédien avec tamedia mes
parents m'ont ri parce que mes parents
sont des bourgeois fae td bourgeois à
bourges où adam ne comprenait pas que
son fils dont il fait du théâtre alors
on allait servir le gosse rien dit puis
on a orienté après en différentes choses
qu est ce qu on vous proposait de faire
des jo a eu lieu
le spectacle va à sa rencontre un
passant laborde dans la rue lui propose
un rôle
il abandonne limay pinces et prend des
cours de comédie
c'était une femme extraordinaire elle
s'appelait serge sicard qui m'a appris
le métier et qui m'a fait travailler
tous les personnages qui ne convenait
pas pour me sortir de mon caractère
pour me sortir de mon personnage que je
skie toujours le personnage d'hal et
pour m'extérioriser qu'est-ce que vous
travaillez cromwell on purge bébé
hamlet qui a fait j'ai travaillé j'ai
travaillé la scène du père d'armand du
vab
il vit de son métier dans un studio ou
salle de bain et cuisine sont installés
à sa taille
[Musique]
y at il des rôles que vous ayez envie de
jouer tous les rôles qu'on ne nous
propose pas sûr on propose des rôles
diane lamarre bon alors je voudrais
faire des rôles de père de famille bongo
va pas car à la ville je pourrais très
bien est un père de famille je suis
célibataire mais je pourrais être marié
et père de famille avoir des enfants de
20 ans maintenant et durant les 80 car
les 999 fois sur 1000 ont des enfants
normaux
il doit y avoir des problèmes pour vous
à jouer sur des scènes installées pour
les acteurs plus grand que vous les
escaliers par exemple ça m'apporte des
difficultés mais ça m'a fait en même
temps et la culture physique
journalières quotidienne de minute en
minute et comme ça va sans le vouloir je
reste en forme
vous n'avez pas plus de problèmes dans
la vie que sur la scène vous savez ces
quotidiens pour moi monsieur l'élu les
gens dans la rue je le vois tous à la
hauteur de la ceinture alors tu as quoi
que ce soit dans la rue ou sur scène
c'est pareil il n'y a pas de différence
pour moi je suis habitué comme ça on
n'éprouve pas une impression de danger
un peu non j'étouffe de 30 ans enfin
j'ai eu à la ce moment là où je passe
les fesses conseil ces cartes vous
étouffez quand vous êtes dans une foule
marque des postérieurs c'était un peu
effrayant
[Musique]
si facile
m
[Musique]